don't walk up to my car please
hey man you can't drive through the
parking lot like that
get your driver's license
any weapons in the car need to worry
about
Ford did you catch my traffic
Robert John Wayne giving 47-32 Robert
Downey four seven three two seven
all right
14 41 65 88 one four four one six five
eight is there any particular reason why
you felt you need to come to the parking
lot like that
I didn't think I did anything wrong I
just came over to get gas do you were
speeding and you cut through parking
spaces and then you can't do that
I mean you walked around it's coming to
get gas yep oh are we gonna go back and
forth or are you just gonna you asked me
a question you want me to answer it or
not I'm not
okay
anything I thought I was going even
slower than normal no sir normally
people don't even park where you park
and that's the direct path to the gas
pumps through the parking spaces I do
realize that I know that there's Parker
spaces there you almost hit that car
that was turning right there I was
watching man in front of me like that I
was like looking and I watched it happen
so I come here every day there's almost
never ever ever anybody you were sitting
there this morning now last week for
about three days someone was parking
there but if I come here 365 days a year
which I do there's someone sitting there
maybe 10 times so there's never ever a
car there so yeah I go through there
because it's the straight path from the
entryway to here which is what you're
going to see everybody else do it but
let me know I hear you man I got it to
you it looked like I was going fast to
me I thought I was going even slower
than normal because I didn't want to get
too close to you
foreign
[Applause]
all right
foreign
I come here every day dude I send
pictures of my wife the price of the gas
here every day when I come through okay
look so okay
not gonna go back and forth
and all that I'm gonna write some
tickets but the only reason I'm not
writing you tickets is because I'm out
of tickets right now okay otherwise you
would be receiving aside for what we'll
do the citation I'm just here
disregarding traffic control device on
private property
okay still you still can't do that it's
still legal okay okay so I'm not gonna
write your ticket
um I hear you man I understand I don't
one I don't appreciate the attitude
I get it you're upset nobody likes cops
pulling them pulling up on them nobody
likes it okay but you know you did wrong
you know you're not supposed to cut
through the parking lot and instead of
being like Oh yeah I messed up sorry it
won't happen again you want to sit here
and go back and forth with me right
there's a lot better things than than
this to be doing for you you're right I
was working on a report be over here I
mean there's people right now you want
to go to jail you want to go to jail so
you want to go to jail you could go to
jail for this
you can do what you want to do I can't
stop I don't want to take you to jail no
that's that is definitely a waste of my
time
okay but the attitude is not necessary
that's on your part sir I haven't been
rude to you at all
very good that's fine I have a camera I
can't be rude to you okay
all right I will get in trouble you go
file a complaint
based on my behavior they will decide
whether or not to get me in trouble yeah
I'm not worried about that
we're good man okay all right well I'll
make sure that I'm there all the time if
I see it happen again then okay we'll go
from there okay okay all right I'll look
that low off that problem I don't
believe
you can do the thing here on this on
this park a lot like that I could also
take you to jail for class B reckless
driving or class I'm sorry class a
reckless driving because you did almost
hit that car I didn't almost hit anybody
I was nowhere near there's there's
cameras everywhere you can do what you
want to do Harold I can't stop you if
you want to be this way then that's up
to you I'm trying to be reasonable
I'm having a bad day because you're
doing this to me have I raised my voice
to you at all sir
you're the only one who's getting upset
I'm upset because I think this is
Victory I think this whole thing is
ridiculous
I think it's ridiculous
that we're even talking about nothing
happened and here we are talking you're
threatening to take me to jail so I
should be getting upset I don't call it
a threat sir no it's a threat it's a so
that is a threat you're threatening to
be under car alone now that so take
something which I don't believe you even
have the authority to do dictionary
terms sir okay it comes from black lives
misdemeanor for you to threaten to
arrest me over something you know it's
not really true what's the penal code on
that sir
trust me that's okay trust you okay I
had
we're good
trust you
working I don't feel like we are I feel
like this is uh
this is a problem
I feel like you're going to continue to
commit these behaviors that are unsafe
and put people at risk
you don't feel like you did anything or
something that's possible they may do
the future so we're now now we're
playing Jean-Claude Van Damme future cop
and you're gonna you need to stop me
from something I may do in the future
that's now your position
you're feeling like you should take
action because maybe sometime in the
future I might possibly continue to do
something come on
what is the law designed to do sir
oh I know you won't design
I know you won't voluntary compliance
wow
do this a different way then
all right well sir I'm concerned that
you're going to continue
to do this unsafe Behavior so
all right
I cannot believe that you're doing this
dude well I mean it it didn't have to go
this way no it never did none of this
ever had needed to happen
I disagree with you okay I know what
would you like me do with your car
I'm gonna call somebody or uh or or do I
tell it
really is this terrible I'm in the the
I didn't think we did
I didn't think we'd give you the Ciroc
man
in fact but I mean you wanted to sit
here and argue with me about what I
observed with my own eyes
yes you even
know if I was talking about yeah okay so
what
I didn't think we were closer I really
didn't no you were very close they had
to slam on their brakes I watched it
happen
okay you came flying through the parking
lot
okay
so what are we gonna do about the park
you you certainly were sir you
definitely were
okay
you definitely were
okay so what are we gonna do with the
car
I don't want to tow it because that's
that that'd be being a real dick and I'm
I'm trying not to be the dick
okay what would you like me to do with
the car sir
I'm gonna ask one more time and then I'm
gonna have to episode
can we back this down dude can we cool
off here please I'm sorry I won't I will
do it forced my hand if I will because
if I don't go and and see this through
to its conclusion I know you're going to
go to the police department and file a
complaint on me now the complaint's not
going to do anything because I have it
all on video everything is recorded I
don't talk to anyone in the public
unless I have my camera on okay
to Harold at all I'm just a little upset
because I I really honestly sir I
watched it happen I was working on
reports definitely have better things I
didn't think that I did anything else I
didn't think I did anything and it was
very first don't think that
but I explained it to you and then you
wanted to argue with me
because I didn't think I did anything I
know I look young this is not my first
day on the job sir I promise nothing to
do with any of that I didn't think I did
anything you almost tried to that white
truck
agree with you that that's what you
think then there's nothing I can do to
change you're gonna be on the cameras
I'm gonna get copies of it
I didn't think I did anything it was
frustrating for me to try to explain to
you that I didn't think that I did
anything and you're not hearing me
I hear you sir I disagree with you
so what do we want to do with the truck
or with the car I'll have to call my
wife I guess okay well let's call her
where's your phone
that's uh well it's in my pocket I just
got through sending her the message
about the okay well how about I'm gonna
give you another set of handcuffs
because like I said I understand if you
get home let me stick this thing right
here what am I being arrested for here
disregard the traffic control device
because a reckless driving charge is a
much much higher charge and again like I
said I don't want to be that big of a
dick
lean forward for me just a little bit
get your phone out
any firearms in the foreign
[Applause]
huh
so my car is going to be you'll find it
over here so
yeah I guess so and then I'll just I
don't well I'll speak to it we'll take
care I'll give her a call if you want to
do I don't know yeah I don't know you're
gonna have to cover work
okay
uh hey I'm Gonna Leave This phone in the
car so that you can get called
okay and then I don't know what how
we're gonna handle that
so
I'll get my other phone in custody
forget that
is
okay there's another phone right there
I'll get it I'll take care of it
we'll put another one I'll show you back
in the heart
all right
make it so don't tighten it okay
so you want this phone left in the car
and the other phone come with you
where's it at
least
[Music]
thank you
very much
you came it's awesome
all sitting right there
he came through the parking lot and cut
through all the spaces and he came
through so fast and whooped into here
and there was a white truck the white
truck had to slam on its brakes so I
come over here I was just gonna be like
hey man so uh like chill out don't be
like that but he wanted to go back and
forth and argue with me and give me all
kinds of stuff and like
I didn't have any tickets and I didn't
grab a rider this morning so I was like
man look this he didn't have to go this
way he kept going back and forth back
and forth so I was like all right
all right
yeah I was I was going to be I'm a dick
but I'm not gonna be that big of a dick
he has a different phone he wanted me to
grab
on gate um
see them
yeah I would have come straight over
here
it happens yeah
46.
where's the other phone at I can't find
it what is a
next to the parking brake delivered in
the center
blue blue phone blue phone it should be
it's blue
Sky
though I don't know anything about him
I get one to go back and forth back and
forth and argue and I was like
if I have a ticket book I just written a
ticket
you have a writer uh
okay
foreign
citation okay and uh
because I think going to jail is a bit
excessive but well
I agree with you but I didn't have
another option I'll have another ticket
book and I don't have a ticket writer
with them so we're gonna do it that way
okay step out for me
no
oh my God
I pressed that scar I mean it hurts
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
no the address here
I think it's uh 15.
tankers 58.85
good address for you
guys 713-668-0500
that's where he is
thank you
give me a second
good
information
good to see if Isaac Jason
[Music]
[Applause]
girl
the show is no longer Festival
it's not an admission Guild it's just a
promise a contact report on a report of
the Dayton time that's written on here
in contact the court at the bottom here
the information's there and also up
there
way to go sir
thank you sir